if you're a fan of Blizzard games you'll
be happy to know that heroes of the
storm is borrowing another character
from overwatch I'm Tony and this is your
ninja fide gamespot news update kenji is
coming to heroes of the storm as part of
the games 2 point 0 update his trait
allows him to jump to a targeted area
and his other abilities are lifted
straight out of overwatch he can throw
shuriken protect himself from enemy
damage with a counter and dash forward
dealing damage in a straight line one of
his heroic abilities is also lifted from
overwatch letting him attack with his
dragon blade for massive damage the
other is an x-shaped strike that deals
both instant and lingering damage to
your enemies Genji seems like a great
addition to the roster but be sure to
LIKE and subscribe to be the first to
know about all the new champions heroes
of the storms two point O update goes
live for everyone on April 25th but you
can get your hands on Genji and the new
ha Nomura map launching alongside him in
the public test realm beta right now and
for more Genji goodness and over watches
latest event you can check out our lobby
discussion on the game's new uprising
mode
[Music]
you